Here's the big picture at a high
level of how we train a q learner.
We have our data here and we select
which data we want to train on,
of course this data in the case of
the stock market is time series.
And so it's arranged from oldest
to newest vertically here.
So we select the day
we want to train on.
And then we iterate over
this data over time.
So we evaluate the situation there and
for
a particular stock that
gives us s our state.
We consult our policy and
that gives us an action.
So we take that action,
plug it into our system here,
evaluate the next state, and
we get our s prime and our reward.
So after one iteration here we've got
an s, an action, an s prime, and an r.
Or an experience tuple, and we use that
experience tuple to update our Q table.
Once we get all the way through the
training data, we test our policy and
we see how well it
performs in a back test.
If it's converged or it's not getting
any better then we say we're done.
If not, we repeat this whole process
all the way through the training data.
So what do we mean by converge?
Well, each time we cycle through
the data training our Q table and
then testing back across that same data,
we get some performance.
And we expect that each time
we complete an iteration here,
our performance is going
to get better and better.
But after a point it finally stops
getting better and it converges.
So overall the chart's going to
look something like this.
Eventually we reach this regime
where more iterations doesn't
make it better and
we call it converged at that point.
Let's consider now in more
detail what happens here when
we're iterating over the data.
So here are the details as we
iterate over our training data.
We start by setting our start time,
which is right here at the beginning and
we initialize our Q table.
The usual way to initialize a Q
table is with small random numbers,
but variations of that are fine.
Now we're here in time and
we observe the features of our stock or
stocks and from those build
up together our state s.
We consult our policy or
in other words we consult Q to find
the best action in the current state.
That gives us a.
Then we step forward and we see what
reward we get and what's our new state.
We now have a complete experience tuple
that we can use to update our Q table.
So we take this information
that we just learned and
we improve Q based on that information.
Then we step to the next
point in time and
the next point time and
the next next one time and so on.
So these are all the details of what
happens in this step of the big picture.